el kremlin ha reaccionado diciendo que
de momento no tiene constancia directa y
oficial por parte del gobierno alemán de
que se han encontrado sustancias
venenosas en el cuerpo de la habana y
que se trataría de un veneno de la
familia de no que el portavoz del
presidente ruso dmitri peskov se ha
escudado en que no hay constancia
oficial de este hallazgo al menos por su
parte sin embargo la familia del
opositor ruso lleva días acusando a las
autoridades rusas de estar detrás de
este envenenamiento
los médicos rusos en cambio dijeron en
su momento que no se habían encontrado
restos de veneno en las pruebas de
sangre y de orina de álex y naval y esto
es a lo que se ha aferrado hoy el
portavoz del presidente ruso dmitri
peskov que ha recordado que cuando
alexéi navalni salió de rusia en un
avión medicalizado rumbo a alemania no
había en su sangre ni rastro de ningún
tipo de veneno